motherfu yeah
Helen coming Saul Alan the
magical pansexual New York City party
one live in the beautiful plush I have
chills okay should we following him I
mean I think we have to what I'm sorry
okay it is not about you right now honey
so we're talking about Palin coming from
from Romy and Michele from the
anniversary party from the good way from
spiceworld Fame Saul I mean Alan
created his own perfume line called
coming hello genie or what I'm wearing
it right now
so I swear to add annoy whatever Alan
has in store for today you will
be titillated
he represents the real New York okay the
the pre 9/11 three Sex in the City
Basquiat Keith Haring New York no we
hearing I'm interested is pickled
herring and as soon as we can get to
that I am fine
okay yourself a deal will do it now
you're something make it happen all
right we gotta catch up with it all
right we got it all here we go we're
losing him okay great oh right we must
we must we must you're a guest you're a
guest
jiggly Caliente is the best suck your
dick between your legs and shake doesn't
easily learn breasts
poor contours and curves all the drinks
that you deserve we are dressed in all
culture just us got clothes I shall the
Lord undo your belt loosen your pants
tip your waitress she's freelanced our
mimosa force will always pass that
[Music]
can I take your order baby yes can I get
a coffee with the side of you I got a
fresh one huh
I love this place thank you and I love
money so make sure y'all tip okay that's
good oh my god Ilana she's at the bar
[Music]
we have to compare respects let's bake
them loosen up a little bit oh so this
is a marijuana pen oh sorry you probably
don't want that why shouldn't I get high
for us you can't get off unless you're
cool hey come on girls oh my gosh
Abbi his friend just left I'm leaving
mom alone at the bar oh my god it's now
or never
[Music]
hello hi mister coming and we just want
to say how big a fans we are thank you
so much for bringing us here today for
bringing you we followed you for like 13
blocks cool see a couple we're just best
friends forever oh it's just yeah we
actually just brought all on a 16-4
cousin because he's a Holocaust survivor
oh really is incredible Mike we really
need to cherish our elders the other
stories you wanna meet sure yeah you
gotta meet my 16 cousin Alan
great
he's right over there where is he
[Music]
okay look dude we'll just see where the
bus stops next okay um uh I can't read a
map no we are okay we cannot be losing
Holocaust survivors not now that the
world is gaining Nazis something out
okay okay okay okay where would a
Holocaust survivor go okay okay
pickled herring to the Mayo base two
salads saw solve Bartlett's Oh sees me
sees me um have you seen an elderly
gentleman like like yay hi he's also
very high as in stone oh he's also
wearing brightly colored LeBron high
tops I don't think so
sorry okay maybe maybe which I've done
sweet a lot uh okay
I never up here and the babka is insane
we gotta get some while we're here I
will get some microcell hey a pound of
white yourself please and we'll take
that to go we're kind of in a hurry
thank you hey dude we're here else with
a Holocaust survivor go
[Music]